[Music]
so I I grew up all over the world my mum
is English my dad's American I grew up
in much of the developing world and have
spent most of my career in intelligence
and development work and journalism
since then also overseas and what I
never what continues to surprise me in
every conversation I have in each
country I go to is how sophisticated
people are at separating the American
citizen from the American government and
I think that we do the same
I would hope in return here in the
United States because we're lucky to
live in a mature democracy I think we
sometimes forget that for many citizens
the actions of their government are
nothing to do with them they have no say
in them whatsoever and are mostly
horrified by what their government does
and so often overseas people who've
grown up in that kind of a government
structure actually assume more than an
American would that when they meet an
American citizen that citizen is in no
way responsible for the actions of the
government because they've grown up in
autocracies where they themselves have
no say in the actions of their
government one of one of the things that
I find I spend a lot of time in Iraq and
there's a sort of fragmentation that
happens on both sides where when I bring
veterans back to Iraq with my
organization operation Zowie which
brings veterans back to war zones to use
their same skills for humanitarian
missions that they were previously using
to wage war when I bring veterans back
to the theaters that they were active in
what I find is that there's this
incredible dual healing that goes on
where the veterans themselves may have
spent two years in theater and never
actually spent time with a local except
through the reinforced glass of their
Humvee
and the local towns person may have
never had any experience with that
veteran that wasn't buffered you know
with an m4 and security on all sides
it's very difficult to build a human
connection with that kind of security
apparatus around you when we're
surrounded by weapons our reptilian
brain defaults to a conflict stance and
when we bring veterans back unarmed to
these same theaters and they work cheek
by jowl with people living in the
refugee camps those who are rebuilding
their homes and build a health clinic
build a Youth Center together with local
Iraqis it's it's almost like watching
someone wave a magic wand and seeing a
curse lift and people blink for the
first time and look at one another and
realize that the person they're seeing
is human there's a real magic to it when
you recognize yourself in someone else
and a lot of the military industrial
complex is intentional sometimes with
good reason and sometimes not it is
intentionally designed to prevent you
from having that recognition humans
don't like to kill one another which is
great news but basic training not just
in the United States but in every
military worldwide is designed to walk
that back to make you believe that your
adversary is something other than human
in order to enable you to kill them
should you need to so I think what we
have you know 10 years into a conflict
is a generation that have been subjected
to that training sometimes necessarily
and now here they are needing to walk
that back and rediscover the humanity in
one another and in so doing the humanity
in themselves and when you watch that
process it's really it's really magical
[Music]